once again got your hands on the Samsung
s6 edge it's kind of difficult to say
what do you think well it's beautiful
phone it's an enzyme here's the s6 and
here is the iphone 6 it's thinner it's a
little bit bigger screen but it's much
faster now the camera is beautiful and
it just feels nice in the end it's all
Gorilla Glass and this little curve Lily
adds a nice touch to it all the other
ones have got basic business this is the
glass on three sides what's what's the
point well it's the idea is that if you
put it down on the table here and there
you're going to alert you can have
different colors i'll tell you who's
calling so you can type it so so if you
know if she's your friend calling it's
one color your mother calling his
another color etc and you know you don't
have to have it face out so that's a way
of getting notifications on it there is
also another version of it which is the
the edge note note edge and that one
actually the curve is bigger so actually
you can look at a clock on the side you
can actually a little ticker on the
bottom I will tell you the things you
can put stock tickers for tickers and
all the rest so you can you know sitting
on a belated if you get a Bloomberg
ticker sort of coming across there why
not okay that sounds like perhaps it has
a little bit more utility is not staying
it looks good yeah so this is the first
time Samsung has upgraded to the metal
bodies which Apple has been doing it's
all clad and it's a unibody they can't
take off that plastic it's all clad in
gorilla glass and it really feels really
good feel it now it does it actually
feels a little bit lighter than my
iphone 6 15 uh and it's faster it's
faster and the camera is fast and it
also has something called this new pay
apple samsung pay so it's lupe so Apple
has the Apple pay which works with the
NFC terminals in other words the special
terminals will accept the contactless
payment but this will work with any mag
stripe a reader so while the Apple will
work with me on 750 million terminals
this will work with every terminal
alright well that can certainly move the
needle for Apple okay so now in my right
hand I've got the iphone 6 in my left
hand I've got the s6 edge apple sold 74
million of these in the fourth quarter
analysts think Samsung's going to ship
55 million of these for all of 2015 is
this going to help Samsung catch up with
Apple
you know I mean Samsung's got a number
of products so they've got a wider
variety of products but now the apple
the Apple fans are gonna do it the real
the real threat is this what's that this
is this is an 1 plus from China so so
whether whether it is a the 1 plus or
exami or whatever the Chinese phones are
really nice they're much less costly and
they're being sold and zillions in China
who makes this one plus one plus that's
the name of the brand it's not as yummy
or Huawei now there was of those they're
also available i just had brought the
one plus one plus Wow uh I like it all
right we're also obviously excited about
the Apple watch today he's reponn three
o'clock in the morning I went out and
took a look yeah well I figured I might
as well figure it out looks like your
rabid no I went I sleep so anyway at
three in the morning the site took about
five minutes to come online once it came
online very few of the watches were
available for the april twenty fourth
most of them were shipping by the four
to six weeks which brought it into May
but it was surprising by just before I
came here the seventeen thousand dollar
watch was listed for August other the
other fancy watches were all listed for
our june so they got demand on there now
I think this is an apple play to
actually try to create demand what is
the utility of it though you know we
keep having people on coming to say oh
it's you know it's a big plus and I'll
have to take your phone out of your
pocket bags I've been wearing a
SmartWatch for about two years now this
is the LG around and I'm good looking
it's actually pretty good looking it's
much cheaper but better the best part
about it though is it runs for two days
or maybe three days without changing
battery which the Apple watch this not
to leave your wrist I don't wanna get
the camera over here this actually looks
like a real watch yeah and you can
change the watch face and everything
else it has all the notifications that
you'd expect this is an LG the new Apple
watch today looks a lot more like those
samsung smart watches how does the
samsung Smart Watch stack up to the
Apple watch in your opinion they're both
have the same problems of battery life
but the Apple watch the gesture when you
flip it up it really works well and the
crown is actually pretty nice so once
you get used to it it's pretty good the
Apple watch is also faster so when you
scroll between the things that's got
that variable thing and it's also got
the variable touch on the touchscreen so
if you press harder you get a different
really look at it so you I wise as you
would expect Apple nailed it experience
wise flipping it up and taking a quick
notification Apple mailed it but but the
watch is I mean the basic watch you're
going to spend about a thousand dollars
it's not subsidized remember this watch
is going to be obsolete in two years I
mean I brought just as an example first
ipod you know more current ipod look at
this i remember this and and this thing
had less memory than this guy does my
god how did anyone go jogging with